[Music]
well as you all know schools are
currently closed school's out for summer
for Kobe could be forever that's the
next life I think by the way Jim max
June max do max that's my prediction
well I mean like then it's summer so
then they'd be out for it so much no
they'd be back in it somewhere they'd
have to you have to make it I don't know
any man it could go a lot of [ __ ]
ways like I hope you know thing we
flatten the curve and it gets a lot
better blinking like a month or two but
when I first heard the flatten the curve
thing I thought it was flat earthers you
were just like no keep the curve that's
a great thing to say good for you means
that were like I looked out my window to
see if the curve got flatter I was like
these [ __ ] flatter
[Laughter]
I should be tweeting again see you're
just like he's like are you idiot still
talking about the car like ten minutes
goes it only would be well Japanese
schools have been closed for a couple
weeks now because of Kobe's and so they
will remain closed and a couple like
elementary school kids they were
supposed to you know not a couple a lot
of elementary school kids they were
supposed to graduate and because around
this time usually school ends in March
and then it begins back in April so
during this closing period a lot of kids
aren't able to graduate if they were
like finishing so these kids they
decided to create their graduation on
minecraft I know it's so cute damn they
recreated the whole way these are
kindergarteners elementary school
they're calling I don't know maybe it's
like between link middle school though
like sixth graders
yeah and then just as boring though what
do ya it was pretty bad all asleep in
those dance significant graduations
always sucks no but they're actually
like they're grabbing things and they're
walking is really I want even go to my
kids
whatever this is your imaginary child
yeah Isaac didn't graduate from
elementary school
why are you gonna have graduations for
elementary school after eighth grade
maybe you didn't graduate maybe this
time be five Isaac's in high school yes
no ho oh well he's about to go in there
no he's not even six no but I'm saying
is it you just got into junior high yeah
it's like close to me two years is
nothing but if you just switch schools
like it's you it's like you started a
whole new career churches true well that
may be that well actually now in
elementary school I don't have no
graduation it was only kidding ago or
preschool cuz he did have a preschool
cut and graduation I still have a cap
and gown it's super cute it's so tiny
and then and in the 8th grade promotion
that's another graduation ceremony and
then high school we had a sixth grade
and we like six sit we had sex
that's it we had a sixth grade
graduation into junior high and then we
had an eighth grade what ceremony and
then yeah I have one I have you switched
schools it was like well you know what
now I'm thinking about it for fifth
grade the last day of fifth grade we did
have like a big ol like it's a party day
they kind of made it like a fair sort of
thing but it wasn't yes that's why the
end of their elementary you made it a
whole like you shake hands with the
principal one by one like they took to
say your name everything that's pretty
cool oh maybe I don't remember
and I stood in front of everything and I
got pissed in my speech didn't get
selected but it's cool wait why would it
why would it be selected
don't say that what do you remember it
so it's been a long time
friends
are you submitted to give a speech
during graduation what do you want to
talk about do you remember
I don't remember I just loved talking in
front of a crowd that is my favorite
thing to do ever legit are you
withholding do I really feel like you
remain I do remember a rap song that I
made up when I was in like ninth grade
but I don't remember the speech I'm so
glad Nikki Nikki scares me some power
man I married a crazy person this is
actually hardening this is good enough
I do remember like people's names from
kindergarten that like left our school
and like never yeah I think that's okay
it's better than like remembering like
this whole speech and then being bitter
about I never got to prosectors you know
yeah also I mean I ran for treasurer
when I was in seventh even once but
that's not the most boring way well I
didn't think that I could make it for
like president or vice president so I
picked one that was like smaller and I
stole a tank and then they had a loser
party and it was like to make it the
principal wanted everyone to feel like
better like cake good for you for like
running and like doing something but it
made me feel like [ __ ] they actually
call it a loser party it was it wasn't
even voluntary we all got pulled out of
class so like well I was a math class or
whatever and then we all got pulled into
the cafeteria and then I looked around
like this everyone that [ __ ] lost
like and then the principal was like hey
good Josh went to say you guys even
though you didn't win the election you
still did something and that mean site
and it was like [ __ ] you that's a Walter
Mondale got told to man he lost like 50
he lost my 49 states to Ray
it's fine okay thank you thank you that
knows that public 15 history so I ran
for ASB president is the vice president
vice president
do you remember your speech yeah I
actually do know because you know what
you know you know what happened no cuz
no so we showed up on the day of and we
went to a baby club right and that and
then we're supposed to give our speech
to the a/v Club and this chick shows up
with costumes and I'm like what the [ __ ]
is she doing and I watched her do her
speech and she like dresses up like a
genie and she does like snap things and
she has to stop and start and so
basically she's like hey I'm Hillary
like whatever you want is your wish is
my command and then she's like just
herself this certain way and then and
then I saw the [ __ ] and I adjusted my
speech and I was like hey like I know
what you guys saw like was like a bunch
of hocus pocus and I thought what I
promised you is that I've like yeah well
you just saw you know that's a bunch of
wishes but what I will give you as your
true dreams come true and we're letting
you tell the truth the whole [ __ ] and
then everything yeah yeah she's full of
[ __ ]
but then the Vice Principal pulls me
into her office it she's like mr. green
I just want you to know that like it's
okay because you lost but like a
significant significant margin I'll
never forget that well how does that
make it okay it makes it okay because
she's letting me know like it wasn't cuz
you never had a chance
David Claus so you have to sweat it
brother
yeah you lost hard there was nothing you
could do I'll save this there's no loser
party they're like why would we finance
a loser party basically yeah but that
that's what my speech was oh my god and
I remember the name first name and last
name this person and
the girl that won 3rd Street I hope her
horrible things happen to her actually
with us you idiot 7th grade I'm kind of
curious what she's doing well
you know I've never heard of her and I
heard of Steve green since then I'll say
that never heard of this Hilary check
this Hilary
it's Mary this dude named Bill hey
nervous
hey you know who Rick Lazio is [ __ ] if I
know we had for Senate in New York he
feels that way about what the [ __ ] is
your problem
classy oh come on boy those Red Claws
Iroquois feel like you could just make
up names and I'd be like oh he ran for
Senate in New York anyway Hillary
Clinton it was like it was it was mm and
why do we care no I'm just relating it
to my high school coach Jimmy he was
right your two balcony or Senate Senate
I just love how you use such relatable
analogies all the time loser did you
learn this that in the year 2000 or you
read now and read all this [ __ ] I know
interesting thank you storylines I love
stories so it's just it's I'm paying
attention to stories since we can't
remember her own life story no I'm not
not allowed it's weird I'm following
public stories not [ __ ] personal [ __ ]
yeah and you remember every football
stat he says it nicer but he does say it
what about what about football stats you
remember every single football star over
year that everyone with team won or ever
and but you but then I am weird because
I remember I'm an ugly ryx
this is why were together because I'm
less a virgin we both
like call go haha you did this thing and
then we both do the same thing that's
time that's awesome so look up Rick
Lazio yeah a great time well it does
sound like loser like Lucia like loser
oh well he [ __ ] up I remember this
because he used to watch ice watch the
show called Carbone Chris Matthews all
every every week I wanna put your fun
kid know why it was actually that I
watched árbol Chris Matthews is because
they're depressing story but no it's
because my parents grounded me because I
was so bad at school that they're like
you can only watch the news from now on
so I was like okay well also watch this
so I watched MSNBC every day and I
watched hardball with Chris Matthews and
Chris Matthews just got taken off the
air for sexual harassment he actually
just oh yeah Matthew's yeah Harbaugh get
the [ __ ] yeah go call her go like he's
that guy so everyone's seen this guy
before at some point an SNL sketch or
whatever and so I remember watching
hardball Chris Matthews and Chris
Matthews at the time was was talking
[ __ ] on crystal and on Rick Lazio
because Rick Lazio walked up to Hillary
Clinton during a debate like just like
this all right
and everyone was like whoa he crowded
her that's [ __ ] up she's a woman
that's [ __ ] up he they conveyed their
personal space and then her campaign was
like yeah he made her personal space
that's like way [ __ ] up like do you
guys by yeah everyone was like yeah we
buy it I think and then bricolage is
like I wasn't trying to be two spaces
just trying to debate her as that she'll
and then every it [ __ ] you Rick loves
you you piece of [ __ ] misogynist
Buckhead and so I remember that and so
that stuck with me so I remember this
[ __ ] that's all that's my memory like
making [ __ ] spite the steve bourie story
fantastic story thank you for sharing
you guys remember Gary Condit know
[Music]
[Music]